i have completely unsurprising
not shocking news for you today a
50-year study of tax cuts
has determined that when you give the
very rich tax cuts
things don't trickle down and inequality
actually gets worse
now if you understand economics at all
you would say
david how is this even a story but
there's a large part of this country
that still thinks you give tax cuts to
the rich
money trickles down and it reduces
inequality and everything's good
this is a paper from the london school
of economics and kings college
london and it looked at 50 years of tax
cuts for the wealthy across 18 different
countries and they evaluated claims like
trickle down uh tax cuts for the rich
trickle down and help the economy
or uh cutting taxes on the rich reduces
inequality and what they found
is that cutting taxes on the rich
increases inequality
gives the rich more money with almost
nothing trickling down below
overall increases inequality and doesn't
improve
economic performance overall it doesn't
lead to economic growth
it doesn't lead to employment growth it
just causes higher income inequality
and one of the things that is important
to understand about this
is that uh there are always going to be
let's divide this up into two ways i
think that for a lot of just average
people
who don't study economics this idea was
always a hard sell
i think to just normal folks who have
not been radicalized to fall for
trickle-down economics if you go to
normal people who just work a job and
don't think too much about it and you
say hey
if we give tax cuts to the really rich
do you think it helps you
you go to a laundromat owner or a
hardware store owner
or a teacher and you say hey we're
giving
billionaires and people with over 50
million in assets we're giving them a
tax cut do you think this will help you
i think that's always been a hard sell
for the average person but there's an
entire movement
that is based around paying
people at think tanks and other places
to claim that tax cuts for the rich are
going to help everybody in some way
and the assumption that really fails is
that when you
cut taxes for the rich more people are
hired
and it fails for a number of different
reasons first of all
most of the money doesn't even enter the
ecosystem of where it would affect
hiring
because rich people have a much higher
savings rate than poor people
if you give a poor person a five percent
reduction
in their tax taxes they're almost
certainly going to spend all of that
money
if you give a really really rich person
a five percent reduction in their taxes
they're going to save most of that money
because they're not counting on that
money to live
and as a result because the money is
just being saved
it's not being spent by rich people in a
way that creates
a need for more employees or a need to
pay employees more money
number two even the money that the rich
do spend at a business only part of that
goes to wages
and mostly that additional spending that
the rich do
goes to profits and part of the hard
costs of the things that they are buying
the driver of hiring we know is demand
it's not labor supply
and this is often an argument that's
missing when talking about illegal
immigration or immigration in general
the the argument
that we hear goes they come here
legally or illegally doesn't for our
economic argument it doesn't matter
they take our jobs and because
they increase the supply of labor
wages go down it's basic economics they
say you bring in a lot more people
looking for work
and companies can pay less and they're
stealing jobs and lowering wages
well remember wages are only part of the
cost of a good or service
and remember that all of those
immigrants in your community
legal or illegal immigrants they also
buy stuff
they also rent apartments they also buy
food
they go to restaurants so what's missing
from this overly simplistic analysis
is that when you have immigrants come in
looking for work
it's a huge increase to demand because
you have more people demanding products
and services
which under the same simple economic
argument would mean
businesses can raise prices and make
more money right
and people only talk about supply of
labor
to argue against immigration and ignore
the other side of that which
is the demand increase which is good for
businesses and this has all been
demonstrated
academically by countless economic
papers so
what what's missing you know anybody
surprised to get back to the main
article
anybody surprised that over 50 years
in 18 different countries cutting taxes
for the rich didn't trickle down but it
just
increased income inequality you you lack
and i'm not saying this pejoratively you
it sounds like you just lack a more
holistic
macroeconomic understanding of course
cutting taxes for the rich
didn't stimulate the economy in the way
that some of these supply ciders think
let me know your thoughts but a
completely unsurprising result